November 2012 astronomers identify a new
planet 100 light-years from Earth at
least four times more massive than
Jupiter and it's gone rogue
unlike earth and all the other objects
in our solar system this planet doesn't
orbit a star
it really is lost in space when I was a
kid watching science fiction movies
every now and again there would be a
rogue planet just some planet wandering
space without a star and I thought that
was pretty silly but it turns out that
might actually happen when planets are
forming they can interact with each
other gravitationally and it's entirely
possible that when our solar system form
planets were kicked out into
interstellar space there could be as
many as 200 billion rogue planets in our
galaxy that's as many rogue planets as
there are stars in the sky and one of
them could be heading our way
a collision with another planet sounds
far-fetched could it really happen
as a matter of fact it already has four
and a half billion years ago a young
planet veers into the Earth's orbit we
have the earth sitting here and another
planet about the size of Mars came in
and smacked us hard the two collided
over 25,000 miles an hour 12 times
faster than a bullet the impact destroys
the smaller planet the earth survives
but only just the violence of this is
hard to imagine two planets coming
together smashing together into one
molten mass after an impact of that
scale the entire surface of the earth is
literally liquefied and imagine the
floor of an active volcano with islands
of solid rock and lava spurting right
and left the entire surface of the
planet would have looked like that the
earth itself for a little while would
have had an atmosphere of molten rock
there was a vision of hell
debris blasted out at 20,000 miles an
hour orbits the molten earth
gravity brings the debris together
the result our moon